like I said today it's not happening
tomorrow but as soon as they [ __ ]
understand how fast it is and it shoes
it gets good and as soon as it's what
Google doesn't do now that voice is
gonna do is he's gonna respond how about
the Tony or voicemail
[Music]
we're gonna be able to what like I if I
hung out with him every single day I
would know his tone of voice your device
is gonna know that so when he's
searching for something it's gonna
understand the context
finances everything if you took your
grandparents when they were 20 and
showed them today with all this [ __ ]
they'd be like look and that's where
people get caught and in ten years it's
like the speed of what's happened last
40 years because it's exponential yeah
[Music]
what's up guys
rainy Tuesday here late May 2018 Moyes
Khan in the building our first voice
conned thrown by vaynermedia Boehner
experienced Kim Garcia Emma the rest of
team just super excited about it
very much feel like voice is where
social media was in 2006 and 7 and
wanted to put a flag in the ground and
events think event marketing in general
for all of you watching is an amazing
place to establish brand and so that's
what we're doing here you've never
thought about what your business sounds
like like sitting here and realizing oh
[ __ ]
I'm gonna have to have a conversation
with my dad Sasha
about what's the voice of Wine Library
sound like is a pretty exciting kind of
conversation just out of humour for me
as a human but I think it's very
important especially you know it's just
something we don't think about it's
something that we could have never
thought about in the same way that we
could have never thought about how
important a logo was for social or
things of that nature or your tagline
things of that nature you know how
unbelievably important over the next
decade or two what your brand sounds
like is actually going to be a variable
of success incredible list of speakers
wonderful content I'm excited about it
in general and just the exciting day
they'll definitely look back on in seven
twelve years of reference you know this
is a great day because we'll probably
reference it six seven eight nine years
from now we can use the footage here and
keep interstitially it into dailyvee
2013 not the year two of us of 2013
figuring out voice is like kind of
session of mine because I think it's
what's gonna happen over the next decade
35 residency perfect
so youngsters you got to hear this back
when we were kids if you wanted to meet
your friend somewhere in public it went
down like this you'd have to tell them
in school that day that you were meeting
at 4:15 and you had a meet by the big
waterfowl and at the [ __ ] mall but
here's where it gets gnarly if for some
weird reason your mom was running lis
and you got there at 425 there was a
50/50 chance that the person gave up and
you never saw them it's just a
remarkable how in a very short period of
time that seems ludicrous because of
this and the biggest framework that I'm
looking for everybody to come away with
this is to dream and imagine and project
how big of a deal voice is going to be
back see dancers take seven before
actually a question from athletic
assault yep how did you start your
speaking career and I'll add on to it
how would you recommend someone starting
sure I randomly got an email that said
hey can you speak at Internet conference
I said sure I went in and [ __ ] slayed
the stage and never looked back the way
I would recommend doing it last night I
said and I'm Trudi rock and can clip
this for you I told Jesse an incredible
artist don't be fancy until your fancy
way too many people with speaking our
fancy before their fancy if they want to
get paid they want to be a headliner
they give like if you want to speak you
need to speak for free like Jerry
Seinfeld and Dave Chappelle and like his
people didn't go over like play Radio
City and get like the complete lack of
people willing to eat [ __ ] to win the
game you want to be a public speaker and
make money and do that whole game great
just like go on you know social media
and you know event pages and like see
events that are going on in your general
area and offer to speak for free fancy
[ __ ]
and be good at it and do it 50 times I
mean I got paid for the first one but
like after that once I got the kind of
like the drug of it I think I spoke for
free for like 38 of the next 40
how many speeches do you think you did
before the web to point out one you
wanna pop 2009 um mm I am 2007 probably
probably
12 to 15 so think about that that's the
one that popped clip it here that Smurf
enough stuff is the best
um and then I still went on to do 20 for
free and I just don't want to do it for
free even though I paid even though I
get paid 150 to 200 thousand dollars of
speech now if its strategic I'll do it
for free don't be fancy until your fancy
can't wait to see you in Toronto I can't
wait to be back Melissa somebody put
your phone number and I'm gonna call you
let's go phone numbers here in Facebook
live because they're going way too fast
up there for me I'm also with first in
line loving it first lines amazing just
give it away free [ __ ] for you so
there's free time [ __ ] it's just
tough to not love first in line if you
were not part of first in line or making
a huge [ __ ] mistake
hit me up on facebook messenger right
now and get the auto reply from the AI
bots and fill out the form you know and
watch awfully good things happen to your
life I'm coming back to Jason to voice
con I'll be right back how to do
something get to the office let's go
Brandon hammer wow yeah hello what up
brother scary B oh man Gary's what's
going on man life is expect this well
you can well you put your [ __ ] phone
number into Facebook like what do you
thinks gonna happen you can look you got
millions of followers man I get it
brother than a million tonight I get it
how are you what can I answer for you
I've been a bad bet a bad bad day my
wife just got her job cut today I'm
sorry that yeah after working for
nonprofit helping special needs kids bad
boss got rid of us so it's a soggy day
what a thing I really just what she do
yeah what does she do that she she's a
minister like fantastic in
we have assisted well you know we're
hiring some of those at Vayner you want
to send her resume to me ASAP I would
love to do it right now I will do that
yes just really we need like yeah I need
to move forward in my slang brother I
know you you're doing your art I know
and all that that's that's that that's
tough to get going but of course it's
just you know I think I think you know
just you know the motivation and
everything you care about this it's just
amazing and you know sometimes life
takes you down you know just trying to
pull yourself back up you know that goes
for almost everybody well you know you
know what I want to do because I got
real love for you've been part of this
community for a long time I'm gonna have
tonight you're gonna send me your wife's
resume Tyler's right here he's gonna
look for that we'll get that in motion
I'll get it over to Claude and the and
our hiring team because we are doing
admin stuff so I'll get her I'll get her
in here ASAP but I want to do something
else I really like the art that you've
made like I know you made that piece for
my dad which I liked I'm gonna and I did
what for your for you but yeah I'm aware
I saw it I saw it in his social here's
what I want to do I want to buy from you
for a couple hundred bucks a piece
five five pieces for some of some of my
homies and hit in the hip hop world who
I'm doing some stuff with I'm gonna up
doing it I'm gonna have Tyler connect
with you so you gonna send me an email
with your wife's resume and you're gonna
email me an invoice four five five
sketches at 300 bucks a pop $1,500 and
he'll tell you [ __ ] and he's gonna tell
you who to make them up okay Wow I
really appreciate it you know this means
everything to me right now
my pleasure brother this is how life
works man like you know like the [ __ ]
odds of me having this downtime to go on
Facebook live the odds of me picking
your phone out of it you know like out
of that whole stream and the odds of it
being the day with what's going on and
like the odds of like me working on this
thing that makes me inspired to like
make these sketches for these people and
and I'm also gonna twist our arm a
little bit make sure they tagged you in
their story when they
Poe
and maybe this could be the beginning of
the beginning I really appreciate it I
might choke up right now no worries man
don't [ __ ] up the email to Tyler
cuz then at all oh yeah I'm gonna do
that right now
alright brother I love you have a good
day I'll be chill man I appreciate it
but doing the right thing so he's the
right thing Babbitt I wish I had a
question for you but I know you're gonna
tell me to just [ __ ] work
you guys help me out along the way
right I love
but the only way you can [ __ ] work
hard is if you actually like it oh yeah
the problem is people do things that
they think are gonna make that money but
they don't like it and then they can't
work hard because they don't like it and
then you can't make the money if you
don't work hard
it's a [ __ ] vicious cycle eight point
of view on this is the word convinced
scares the [ __ ] out of me
I've spent my whole career talking about
stuff that most people don't believe at
the time that I start talking about it
and I have found for the last twenty
five years that I'm way better off just
continuing to talk about it and not
convincing people but letting the market
force them into my world you would be
way better off if you decide to do
something here to go to everybody and
focus on the three people of 418 that do
it with you and do it amazing for them
than to sit there and try to convince
people that are never gonna go there
commencing the unfirm in scible is just
a terrible strategy that i see so many
people spending their time with i mean i
sometimes go into a pitch and I'm
fundamentally checked out within the
first ten minutes I'm like this is over
like we're here to check a box that they
wanted somebody innovative to be here
they're out and I'm like and what's
crazy is I'm not like [ __ ] like I'm a
mad at its business I signed up for this
I just am not emotional about convincing
people I am thrilled to just stay alive
until it happens and then look at them
and say [ __ ] told you dick
[Music]